six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number we will take
our next caller and let's start with
your name and where you're calling from
hello my name is Brody you hear me yes
we can what's on your mind Brody okay
awesome cool there's no on your phone
screen system it doesn't give me an
indication of God anyway um you made an
awesome super duper important point
about perception of Republicans
especially regarding the Affordable Care
Act as an anecdote there were a group of
hospital executives in North Texas you
have jokes it would even be worth
wasting their time trying to avoid not
working with patients to have to go and
try and get Rick Perry to accept 95% of
the federal funding like you mentioned
that is literally giving people Medicaid
which they'll be denied access to um
states with Republican governors don't
have access to so it's a clear interest
idea where there's people voting against
actually their own ideas and it's
costing billions of dollars and millions
of lives that are you know lots of lives
do you think that there's something
about we can do in terms of educating
people about the results of their
choices yes or better it kind of just
just get so far away from reality or do
we need like the bonus size David Pakman
Coffee it's just so insane yeah you're
gonna need the two pound bag of David
Pakman espresso to do honestly I don't
know the answer I mean it's like what
we're trying to make it so that people
understand that your election the
decisions you make at the voting booth
have consequences and when you vote for
a Republican governor who turns down the
Medicaid expansion as you so eloquently
put it Brody and then you blame
President Obama for Obamacare when in
reality that Obamacare would have funded
ninety five percent of your state's
Medicaid expansion and you blame Obama
instead of your own governor and then go
and vote for your governor to be
reelected I don't know I don't know how
you can fix that and we've seen this
with the Tea Party a group that is built
on voting for candidates that support
the interests of others and not then I
don't know what we can do I really don't
I wish I had in concerning to cuz like
yeah there's an education like time
that's running out yeah I don't know I
just thought maybe if you could maybe
sometime expand on that
awesome show man all right let's Brody
really appreciate the call much
appreciate that's something we're going
to continue working on for sure